So anyways,
Pinocchio was transformed into a victim
and he's offered this,
he's offered this identity and he takes
it.
Now,
it's partly because he's deceived and
manipulated,
but it's also partly because of the fox
offers him the abandonment of
responsibility as payment for as payment
for adopting the victim identity.
So this is where his own lack of
morality,
let's say,
because this is all about Pinocchio.
Development as a character plays a role
in his demise.
So if I'm a victim than everyone else
owes me something and I don't have to
take any responsibility.
And so one of the things I've wondered,
here's something to think about.
It might be that the sense of meaning
that life can provide to you is
proportionate to the amount of
responsibility you decide to take on.
Not.
That'd be very strange if it was the
case,
you know,
because responsibility of course is a
kind of weight obviously,
and it's difficult to take on
responsibility,
but if any positive emotion that you
feel and your control of anxiety and the
control over pain is dependent on the
activation of these systems that watch
you move towards a desired goal,
then the more complete and weighty the
goal is,
the more kicked there's going to be in
the observation that you're moving
towards it.
And,
uh,
you know,
you kinda already know this because
you'll,
you'll have observed in your own life
that when you're engaged in something
that you believe in,
that the time passes properly,
you know,
you can see this even if you're,
maybe you're reading a paper and it's
actually related in some intelligible
manner to something that you want to
learn.
So even though it's difficult,
you get engaged in it,
you can remember it better,
you can process it better and you don't.
You're not so likely to fall asleep and
you're not so likely to want to find
distractions.
All of that,
you can get into it and it would be very
interesting if that was proportionate to
the degree of responsibility that you're
willing to shoulder and I think you can
make a strong case for that.
I've also often wondered,
imagine you could offer people a choice.
Here's the choice.
You could say,
well,
your life isn't meaningful.
Denialists have got it right.
There's no meaning in your life and
because of that,
there's no reason for you to accept any
responsibility so you can live a
responsibility for your life and maybe
one of the impulsive pleasure seeking
better responsibility,
free life,
but the price you pay is that it doesn't
get to be meaningful.
Or you could say to someone,
no,
we're going to do the opposite.
We're going to say you can live a
meaningful life,
but it's only going to be as meaningful
as the amount of responsibility that
you're willing to bear.
And then you might say,
well,
what would people choose?
Because everybody also always makes
noises about wanting to have a
meaningful life,
but if the price you pay for that is the
adoption of responsibility that it's not
so obvious that people would choose
meaning over,
you know,
over pointless pursuits if they had to,
if the benefit they go out for choosing
the pointless pursuits was that they
really didn't have to care about
anything they ever did.
Right?
Snow responsibility.
And that's really what Pinocchio is
offered.
And that's what the coachman offers
them.
And that's interesting because,
you know,
so far it's been the Fox and the cat and
they were kind of to bid hoods.
And so the pathological pathway that
they offer Pinocchio is not the worst of
the pathological pathways,
but here,
at least as far as the imagination,
the collective imagination that created
this movie is concerned,
is this is where you get to the most
pathological form of,
let's call it temptation.
And that's the temptation to engage in,
to abandon responsibility and to engage
in impulsive,
pleasure seeking short term pleasure
seeking.
So here's the Fox pretending to be a
doctor investigating,
um,
Pinocchio's illness.
And He makes some notes,
which is all just meaningless,
scribbled,
right?
It's like white noise and it doesn't
matter that the arguments that he's
making is are completely incoherent and
it doesn't matter that he actually
doesn't know anything.
He what he's selling is easy to buy.
And so Pinocchio buys it and by the end
of the conversation with the Fox,
he's pretty convinced that he's useless
and it needs a vacation.
No,
this is anita postage inedible situation
as well,
which I touched on the other lecture.
I mean,
that's fair.
Let's imagine that you have a child that
is a little on the neurotic side,
so high negative emotion and maybe one
that's also a little bit on the east
side,
so has a variety of,
let's say relatively minor ailments,
but the ailments nonetheless.
So what that means as a parent will say,
mother,
for this example,
because I want to use the apple example,
you have to make a decision all the time
about exactly how you're going to treat
that child.
One decision is,
well,
I'm not gonna.
You don't have to go to school today
because you're not feeling well.
It's like fair enough,
but do you make the same decision the
next day and do you make the same
decision the next day and let's imagine
that you enable the child to avoid
responsibility as a consequence of
capitalizing on their illness.
Well then that's not going to be very
good for the child.
The rule within a sickly child has to be
something like,
I'm going to push you right to your
limit because otherwise,
how is the person going to figure out
what they can do?
And if they can't figure out what they
can do,
then you're not going to be able to make
their way in the world at all.
And then that gets muddied very badly.
If you're not exactly sure that you want
them to make their way in the world.
You know,
maybe you're just as happy because you'd
be sitting at home alone if your child
was there with you and maybe you'd be
just as happy at some level if they
never grew up at all because then they
won't leave.
And so,
and maybe that's because you have a
terrible marriage and your lonesome.
You know,
maybe it's an abusive marriage and your
husband has chased away all your friends
and so you don't have anything at all
and maybe that's because he didn't stand
up for yourself very well apart from the
fact that he was,
you know,
tyrannical and is central nature and so
then all those little warps and bends in
your psyche are going to manifest
themselves.
Right,
right.
In the background of every single one of
those decisions.
My daughter had a lot of illnesses when
she was an adolescent and they were very
serious and it was very difficult to
figure out what to do about that because
you couldn't exactly apply normative
rules.
Right.
And we always had to figure out if she
was
communicating her symptoms to us,
how seriously to take those and dancer
was the least amount of serious
possible.
It's something like that because we
needed to do and she needed to know what
she could do in spite of the fact that
she had problems.
And one of the things I really tried to
instill in her,
and I think it worked,
is that you don't ever want to use it
your illness as an excuse for not doing
anything,
not consciously.
You know,
sometimes you might not know,
I'm not feeling well.
How?
What can I do?
What you don't know,
right?
Because sometimes when you're not
feeling well,
you can do more than you think.
And sometimes you can do less than you
think.
It's not like it's obvious,
but sometimes it's obvious.
You know this little temptation flits
through your mind and you think,
well,
I don't really want to do what I'm doing
today and I'm not feeling very well so I
don't have to do it.
You do that 100 times.
Then you don't know how sick you are
anymore and then you're.
Then you're in real trouble because not
only are you sick,
but you actually have.
You've muddied the waters and so you
have both problems.
That is you're actually ill and you've
betrayed yourself by using that as an
excuse not to pursue your
responsibilities and not.
I think if you do both of those,
both of those things happened to you at
the same time.
You're in real trouble and it's really
hard not to have that happen.
So anyways,
I know gail gets enticed into believing
that he's the victim.
The fact that he's insufficient is used
as an excuse by the Fox and the and the
cat to offer him a trip to pleasure
island,
and this is,
I think where the movie gets
particularly dark and so off they go
singing away.
They have to carry them.
So you could say,
in some sense,
he's carried by societal pathology and
his own trouble.
He's carried like a puppet off to
pleasure island.